welcome to this video the opening
challenges in effect so II for let's see
the trash again I have I should play the
pond Sione as much as possible but I
don't get you only five ok interesting
very early f6
this looks like a decent way of
developing does jet hope I'm not falling
oh yeah no Jen going down to some kind
of tactic it's quite often happening
actually or interesting check in this
line that some tactic is some going to
be a problem for white but not anymore
with Queens traded I'm definitely okay
here so um how am I going to play him
definitely nice white with the space
there mmm can I try let's start with
this
see file is open okay so he tries to
maybe gain control there was some light
square so I'm going a b3 preventing a
form and I have Knight c3 b-52 g6 as a
possibility so let's see 93 coming next
okay so I see it trying to honestly
trying to do night over to a 6 no wow b6
didn't see that one coming push up a 6
97 wins material so so f5 I mean this
looks like it approaches territory like
like it looks like i can should punish
this this is what i'm trying to say so
let's do this f5
yeah maybe I should play 1.e4 more often
i keep get some nice positions there I
mean I'm not really dissatisfied with my
opening results in the in the the d4 and
deform lines but that's it's really nice
here this position so um if I take is
six is going to go to d8 I guess I know
he gives me the rock you is there reason
not to take it let me think though I
mean maybe I even have something better
by g5 no I'm just taking just take a
look let's take a look yes before but I
don't really see a big point down so i
take taking b6 now on yeah I guess I see
it is also hain I mean hanging not
hanging but up for the taking let's say
so i can check now and take this and
there's no nothing happening what is
easiest here probably doubling here on
the sea farm
exchange I'm up an exchange and the pawn
like us to move the night again how to
do this 95 is probably a good move if he
takes no that's not possible sorry
stupid idea maybe that just keeps these
pieces at bay rook 1c3 maybe if you yeah
and a 95 was my idea that's quite nice
no come on there must be some kind of
check made now isn't there made
somewhere or rookie seven lucky seven is
good no
intermediate check in check black
resigns oh what a nice position there
that I got them okay I think that
probably this isn't the greatest idea
here this is this thing that you already
f6 and then Jack connection will chat
with all that it just leaves you a noise
endgame for wide so rooks you won a 50 B
3 so I think if he goes Knight b6 Bishop
d7 now why it should be a bit bad habit
doesn't seem like the end of the world
but yet it approaches the territory of
being being really bad I mean and their
multiple things so night a four is good
already but I don't know okay I went
here just one opportunity ikea no f5
here compass on plus 2 and climbing
teach ethics and now I thought King the
aid I wasn't completely sure how to
continue one simple thing is just to
take them just take him this again still
cannot take from 97 and what is his move
his piece is not exactly very mobile he
moves the night I have this one for
possible route d6 chance impossible
impossible really to save Jackie I went
further for a simple way to convert it i
think it was ok here now 95 crook d7 was
a bit easier even but this was check on
checks yeah it's a it's a series of
checks it's a bit bit easier but a win
is a win yeah in this some in this
opening here black I think should
probably really go and Queen B 6 this is
the main line you can go Bishop e7 or f5
yeah there are alternatives but those
are relatively passive probably Queen B
6
the way to get some active play okay
well thanks for watching